salut et bienvenue dans une vidéo qui
risque d'être ouf
alléchant mais à mort parce que je
mélange un concept et une invitée trop
bien vous avez vu dans le titre c'est
clara morgane et le concept qui nous est
venu avec l'équipe c'est de réunir plein
de gens qui ont des liens entre eux donc
ils peuvent être de la même famille
frère et soeur etc
et nous à la fin on doit déterminer qui
en couple avec qui qui est de la même
famille de kiki est juste un pote de qui
voilà c'est juste ça le concept on va
faire ça ici on avait fait les jeux de
rôle là au petit palais des glaces donc
qui vont s'installer un peu partout j'ai
vu personne c'est loïc fanny et pierre
qui ont encore une fois recrutés et miss
est en place dans mon dos bonne vidéo
avoua aux fêtes loïc génériques
[Musique]
merci beaucoup à vous tous d'être là
aujourd'hui je vous présente l'armorial
salle on sait donc qu'il ya des liens
entre vous qui vous unit c'est à dire
vous vous vous et vous et on sait quel
type de lien on sait que parmi vous il
ya un coût ne sais pas si c'est un
couple hétéro ou un couple homo on sait
qu'il ya deux amis on sait qu'il ya une
sorte de cousine à d'une fratrie sans
connaître les genres un duo parent
enfant et nous on va essayer de vous
poser des questions et vous allez je
crois pouvoir mentir on va bientôt
connaître le brief que vous vous avez eu
l'idée c'est que clara et moi on arrive
à enquêter sur eux et à savoir les liens
qui vous unissent
si tu veux c'est toi qui va mener la
danse clara parce que maintenant tu
aimais meneuse de revue de ce café c'est
vrai t'as un spectacle qui s'appelle le
cabaret temps mangane c'est un spectacle
d'une heure quarante qu'on joue en
résidence à paris actuellement au césar
palace temps le 15e arrondissement de
paris j'ai une troupe d'artistes autour
de moi alors je change d'un jour avec
une chanson que j'ai reprise ya quelques
temps qui s'appelle m6 a est une version
jazz et il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
talent autour de moi et je suis le fil
rouge de tout ce spectacle et vous avez
un lien dans la description de cette
vidéo pour avoir toutes les infos pour
aller au césar palace et pour aller voir
le spectacle avec toutes les dates et
500 pour l'instant c'est reconduit
jusqu'en juin pour les mains maintenant
j'en appelle à une info qui va être
importante pour nous à savoir qu'est ce
que ils ont eu comme brief de la part de
mon équipe donc j'appelle pierre bock
alors du coup en fait on a vérifié si tu
arrêter de m'humilier au niveau de la
taille
non on va dire que je suis plus loin que
toi alors du coup en fait on à
dispatcher les participants en duo et le
but du jeu pour vous donc c'est de
retrouver les bons duos parce qu'ils
sont mélangés ou pas et on leur a donné
comme consigne qu'il avait le droit de
mentir
un petit peu j'essaye de dire au maximum
la vérité mais si ça devient trop
proches de leurs secrets on va dire
ouais ils ont le droit de monter
d'accord corner secretstory mois
exactement sur ce je vous souhaite bonne
chance à pyatov
bonjour messieurs bonjour quelles sont
vos prénoms sébastien sylvain sébastien
enchanté salut sébastien c'est ça
sylvain c'est ça ce serait terrible si
vous connaissiez pas avant parce que
vous avez quand même un truc une forme
de ressemblance dans le style ou autre
mais radin la lettre s
sébastien et sylvain versement way we le
frère c'est possible aussi
mais ils sont quasiment de la même
génération du même âge après ça peut
être que j'ai moi aussi je sais pas
parce que comme il fait de la réponse
réflexe de base
si la vérité pour le coup je pense qu'il
dit la vérité quand les digues sont pas
jumeaux parce que c'est pas des
maréchaux vous parliez pas ensemble
parce que vous avez fait rien à vous
dire parce que vous vous êtes rencontrés
qu'aujourd'hui non non je n'en voyais ça
c'est le genre de mec tu vois quand l
événement au poker quand on lui dit tu
as une bonne main il fait au attend que
ça
moi je dis qu'ils sont frères même
pardon mais vous ressembler beaucoup ok
on a une option sur frère dans notre
tête on change du coup quand vous
appelez vous enchanter et louis emilie
et louis d'individus saf et émile oui
c'est gênant petit séparation entre vous
je vous donnez vous la main pour moi
j'essaye de faire des pièges aussi si
vraiment il hésite si c'est gênant ça
peut être qu'ils se connaissent pas ou
je trouve qu'ils se ressemblent aussi
[Musique]
attend que ça non à une très grande ne
bouge pas patois il 60 comme des cousins
ah oui c'est possible il peut y avoir
une option cuisine ou alors ils se
connaissent pas du tout ce que vous
pouvez vous regarder dans les yeux et en
scène au regard des très gêné est ce que
les masses non risque n'est ce pas du
tout tu es beaucoup trop gêné pour ça
elle était plus générale regarder qu'à
regarder la caméra alors que c'est un
truc flippant quand même de regarder une
caméra non je pense qu'ils se
connaissent pas ok moi je vais attaquer
de toi tu en manges tu me réponds ce que
tu veux tu peux mentir dire la vérité
mais du coup tu étais venu avec un
garçon c'est ça avec un oui ok vous avec
une fille non s'est tenue avec une fille
c'est simple tu es venu avec un des gars
qui a derrière c'est ça
bon là on sait que non mais du coup
comme on sait que non du coup je pense
qu'il est vraiment venir avec avec un
autre garçon moi j'opte pour ça mais ça
c'est juste la petite analyse
comportementale parce que ce qu'ils ont
fait la différence entre toi et moi
finalement pas sinon est-ce que tu le
stress en même temps sinon elle elle me
murray très bien l'intimidation
tu vois je vais rencontrer si elle le
fait volontairement c'est incroyable tu
veux qu'on continue par où c'est toi la
chef la wii mais c'est très bizarre
genre un peu séparés elle allait
maintenant être super stressé alexis
d'accord jessica d'accord ah mais oui
c'est vrai en fait c'est quoi aussi je
commence à psychoter je me dis si elles
sont et c'est pas parce que tu as dit ou
alors si ça trouve ils sont malins oui
et comme non les abris faits dénoncés
par comme ça on leur fait croire que je
ne touche pas la suisse a d'ailleurs le
seul le couple qui pourrait avoir peur
d'être trop près c'est le couple c'est
le guinness book
alexis pourquoi tu ne naît pas plus
proche de notre cher le second de
questions je peux me rapprocher cela
approché mais pourquoi vous avez créé ce
gaz naturel entre vous gênait pas du
tout ce que c'est vraiment une grosse
bulle tu es tu as besoin d'une grande
bulle d'intimité dans ta vie non pas
forcément
aucun sens au fait que vous soyez
launière c'était ce que je suis en
couple et que c'est juste un ami il
faudrait pas qu un ami alors qu'elle
connaissait un ennemi pour ils se
connaissent
un vol à bord on a des enfants est
d'accord c'est à dire cimenter la samba
sy ouais non mais c'est ça ouais donc on
est d'accord ils se connaissent je
pourrais je te suis là dessus c'est toi
qui t'es inscrits pour participer à la
vidéo ou pas n'ont séduit de salut et la
dit quand après a tout de suite en fait
il m'a la fin il m'a demandé s'il ya ni
la vue c'était surtout sur twitter
immédiate donc sortir ensemble à ce
moment là on gagne un message c'est
chaud bien d'avoir la maman bon joueur
c'est quand même prénom sophie sophie et
sophie et mathilde d'accord ok on écoute
on a envie de cataloguer maman
tout à fait
rappel notre prime pardon ah oui comme
quoi l'habit du botaniste samarie
justement est-ce que ça vous dérange les
filles vous mettre toutes les deux au
premier rang se fille et emilie du cou
de cygne de l'autre côté de sophie du
coup après les filles elles ont rien
avoir en commun ce que serait la maman
de défis c'est là qu'elle ta fille c'est
quoi ton groupe sanguin quatre problèmes
vaut mieux savoir et vous connaissiez
voulais finir ces jeunes et quand je dis
ça cesse liège et à 6 voire témoins si
sophie
comment avez-vous savent à quel est ton
prénom
manon et thomas et thomas pas mon temps
ou le toucher ou vous toucher ou pas
mais c'est vrai le trophée terre
d'importance en fait maintenant tu sais
toi qui vous inscrire cette eau martin 7
et a3 vous allez me dire quand est ce
que c'était en même temps 1 2 3 de la
semaine derrière mais je vous jure pas
les n'est qu'en août
c'est pas mal parce que a priori c'est
vrai et c'est rachida assez chaud
taignons oui c'est vraiment corriger
est-ce que ça savent peut être pas où va
cette vidéo me rend fou
j'ai en train de remettre tout en
question et à l'aîné quand converser en
même temps il ya tellement parce que en
vrai le temps qu'on se fasse maquiller
et où ils ont eu le temps d'échanger et
de se passer des petites infos c'est
quoi son plat préféré le bas quand même
ça fait un truc du hockey d'une petite
option couple ici comme highway si quoi
je suis d'accord ouais ouais tu fais
quoi là les jeunes en école d'ingénieur
et bts commercial joie commerce etc
risquent communication timmy question
ouais ça non c'est pas un peu plus c'est
pas possible
peut-être conduit à tous que centre
commercial et communication aussi dans
quoi tu vois
[Musique]
pourtant appelé mes yeux peut venir
excuse-moi sophie si le but était de
mettre à côté de man band cas je
trouverai pas ça dingue et si on disait
que c'était sa fille mais quand même j'y
crois pas trop
c'est juste les yeux mois et les couples
à 30 sa suite ont fait ça n'ont rien à
part il ya konan et or donc à temps bien
on doit se mettre sur scène comme ça on
va vous voir vision dans ce cas les gens
ont la consigne d'avoir la liberté de
mentir on se rend compte qu'on doute de
tout temps de vous tous
presque parce que je vais te donner un
petit ajout ce qui peut le garder
toujours devant toi et puis ok nous on
pense que vous êtes les frangins ça ne
fait quand même plus qu i personne que
quatre possibilités en coupe du marigot
j'en appelle à ton instinct féminin
arrêté par un ace que c'était un couple
marié
on va dire par marion barry je m'en
doutais parce qu'ils sont quand même
tous très jeunes
c'est jessica c'est ça ton prénom
jessica vraiment elle me faisait pas
depuis qu'on parle du couple cosy et pas
prêts on peut se marier avec sa cousine
pour se marier après pascal diot peut
être rsa est marié et en même temps un
peu à me vois pas comment tu t'appelles
matières mates culte avec un trop jeune
ball
tu es jeune quel âge tu as quel âge tu
pètes à 15 16 ans regarde la seule
personne qui pourrait peser en co op et
ambre web
oui d'accord il habite en vous invitez
ensemble vous habiter ensemble la langue
de bois le fait pas du ciel non mais
celle qui peut vraiment habitée par nom
ou par contre tu as raison on est
d'accord qu'on va donner par enfant
assaut final peut lui mettre le parent
enfant pour l'instant à manon belge
responsable quand même c'est quoi c'est
celle qui physiquement s'y prête le plus
parce que pas même sourire en tout cas
non c'était intentionnel de ton papa
atou il a commencé par faire louis
campora helmand est-ce qu'on pourrait
mettre ça en replay dans la vidéo valve
fait sûrement emilie et thomas bah oui
c'est vrai que ça marche aussi en
comparaison des raisons tout à fait
possible du hunan à emilie thomas lajus
pour l'instant brevets
partenaires sportifs ah oui moi j'étais
resté un ami mais ses partenaires
sportifs
mais c'est quoi alors ils sont amis et
partenaires sportifs
ok a déjoué 1 912 aller de la phase très
marrant ça aide un petit truc dans le
visage
jessica et louis seraient en couple nom
serait partenaire sportif ami jean
qu'espères tu fais et en même temps le
profil de skate 2 lui va très bien et je
le profil de commandes y est un
pratiquant de taekwondo iphone os et il
son côté j'espère qu'elle connaît la
réponse des pions comment ça s'appelle
juste de faire un petit saut avec de
faire un petit saut pour sauter trottoir
par exemple s'appelle grand tokyo
ok c'est un bon mois ce que c'est un
divorce que j'ai tendance à mettre les
deux mecs un sport ensemble
[Applaudissements]
donc ça veut dire qu'ils sont 10 sport
dont 100 milliards que vous feriez du
sport on sait pas définitif on veut
encore posé des trucs mais c'est bon ça
me faisait vraiment du taekwondo et oui
je les vois plus mon bios calade
mais les deux en plus quand même ils ont
une position dans le sol mais ils sont
vraiment dans le sol tu vois et c'est
pour ça que ça me paraît pas déconnant
que ce soit les deux sportifs mois en
fait je l'aimé comme ça pompe parce
qu'ils ont tous les deux profils sportif
mais je n'aurai plus besoin de départ
mais en fait maintenant les cousines je
trouve que c'est mal je le jeu me comme
ça je sais pas ce que je pourrais bouger
sans casse et d'autres choses qui je
trouve vont bien ensemble qui croit
vraiment que c'est un coup est ce que
monsieur là vous ne mentez plus parce
que vous êtes frère oui oui bon c'était
moi le plus dur mais merci à vous voulez
ce brestois et merci beaucoup
comme ça j'ai l'impression qu'on n'y
voit plus clair même si on pensait que
c'était le cas sophie et manon moi c'est
ce qui me paraît le plus crédible
finalement ici avancer les filles est ce
que tu peux nous dire le nom de ton
enfant sophie
et les nombres d'années rc voire même si
oui pour vous regarde toujours ce qui
nous embête depuis débarras je ne savais
pas de l'ebn problème non je pense qu'on
a bon si les partenaires sportifs je
tenterais bien la vérification sur les
dégâts ouais d'avancé avant que vous
répondiez bien je tiens à préciser que
je savais bien des paysans et à l'
avance à 6 s'il te plaît lui un loup
sera bien vite maintenant pour moi ils
se connaissent ouais je pense est ce que
parce que vous êtes partenaires sportifs
oui oui oui oui alors ce mot parce que
j'y voyais ces escalades est-ce qu'elle
a du coup reste floue de felitta connaît
aussi ensemble aussi non non d'accord
auquel les travaux et j'hésitais grave
entre cousins mais je me dis du coup moi
ça va nous libérer quoi vous laisse vous
asseoir les m merci donc très bien juste
juste un petit piège parce que vous êtes
mon épouse un site web et du coup si on
avait mis cousin là tu vois
qu'est ce que tu veux moi je croyais
qu'ils se connaissaient pas il nous
reste l'iran paraît délicat je te laisse
pas faire les coiffes en film au cinéma
le dernier au cinéma l'an dernier maïs
et toi aussi tu l'as vu oui en tout cas
c'est ce double sa cousine
c'est sûr qu'on allait conditionner vous
pouvez avancer toute la dalle est ce que
vous êtes bien plus il nous a débloqué 2
vous êtes vraiment en couple alors est
ce que vous m'avez demandé mon âge à sa
soeur sont pas du tout posé des
problèmes
25 kw à 6 et 36 oui j'aurais pas dit 36
par contre j'aurais dû la trentaine la
petite trentaine 2009 30
je le fais pas lara tu as pu vivre le
stress que je vis moi pour le ciel de
faire des trucs au mentaliste que la
quantifier bah en fait c'est à dire
qu'il ya des moments tu es sûr mais
comme il faut de la firme était là on
fait peut-être rien dire et tout est a
été super forte
non mais moi je suis le bon rôle parce
que c'est le second rôle et du coup je
sens votre conseil mais je me mouille
pas n'y a pas deux ouais mais souvent
quand j'avais des choses physiquement
déjà dit moi je voyais pas et de
débloquer 2 3 fois la situation est
maintenant est la fille j'avoue je
m'attribue un peu là bas oui et même le
déblocage final en passant par le cinéma
c'est toi qui va donc cesser trop bien
si c'est gentil mais si tu cherches une
assistante parfois j'ai quelques après
le cabaret ch après le cabaret le cabba
je le rappelle c'est cette affiche là et
c'est le lien qui est dans cette
description pour aller voir le spectacle
de clara morgane mais kaka et de clara
morgane c'est tous les mois aux césars
pas la drogue
ma part est allé voir ça merci beaucoup
clara merci merci à tous évidemment
merci à toutes les personnes qui ont
bien voulu participer vous avez vu le
message possible sur les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes inscrits auprès de fanny
pierre et loïck il faut savoir une chose
c'est que loïc pierre et fanny n'ont pas
demandé les photos des participants
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on pouvait pas
savoir que les frères se ressemblait
tellement et je sais plus bas voilà tu
vois comme quoi tu es trop discret je ne
voyais pas donc ça c'est important de
savoir ils ont découvert aussi des
visages aujourd'hui et puis clara et moi
du coup pareil je suis très étonné de la
pertinence des analyses de clara à la
fin la débloquer des trucs et même
plusieurs fois la trouver des choses
hyper précises comme quoi si elle le
beau c'est un peu elle pourrait encore
plus s'améliorer et faire ça sans moi
sans aucun problème merci à vous tous
d'être venus
mathilde je mets ton instagram dans la
description
parce que c'est comme ça bascule j'ai
demandé qui voulait que je mette un lien
donc vous avez le lien berlin stade
mathilde en descriptions ici vous pouvez
vous abonner ici vous avez une vidéo
c'est la dernière qui est sortie et ça
c'est une vidéo incroyable mais je sais
pas encore laquelle je m merci beaucoup
d'avoir gardé pour s'appliquer à très
bientôt ciao